let's start with the family update I'm
concerned as a family member
Joaquin the infant Keeney he broke his
nose the wrestling tournament this
weekend Kelly Ripa revealing how her
youngest child 16 year old Joaquin broke
his nose over the weekend on live with
Kelly and Ryan Wednesday morning he took
a knee to the nose he was wrestling one
of his good buddies as a matter of fact
from our point of view it looked like he
got poked in the eye and and so I was
like I get it that hurts and sometimes
your eye like it won't open but we were
like all right whoa and then they see
like Pete then there's like a medic out
there and they're wiping the blood off
of him turns out the injury was way
worse than Kelly thought we decided that
nothing was off-limits the 49 year old
TV host shared before and after pics of
her son on Instagram alongside the
caption you win some you lose some and
sometimes you get a tampon shoved up
your nose yes you heard that correctly
and look closely
poor Joaquin had not one but two tampons
in there Kelly told co-host to Ryan
Seacrest that standard wrestling
protocol did you know that if you break
your nose while you're wrestling that
they put tampons up there I think
they're like oh oh oh B or you know like
there's a small tampon he doesn't have a
Kotex security up there on the plus side
Joaquin won the match but it seems to be
a very accident-prone 2020 for the team
at live earlier this month Ryan took a
spill while trying to catch a gold
balloon and well we'll just let you
watch it for yourself
Jasmine gold from Buffalo Neil
[Applause]
luckily the 45 year old TV personality
laughed it off and later posted the
moment on Instagram writing first bumble
of the new season hope I make the
playoffs when Ryan and I hosted together
it seemed like it I would I said is it
it's felt like a ten minute show it felt
like ten minutes and that's when you
know it's a really good pairing back to
Joaquin he's the cup of last child
living at home they're other kids Lola
and Michael are away at college by the
way he's in Vancouver yeah
so here's how Kelly and Mark told ET
they planned to make the most of their
empty house I'm truly going to be
running through the house furniture
naked come over that's what I'll be
doing in my spare welcome America
[Music]